with coronavirus infection rates
exploding across the u.s
experts are pushing state and local
leaders to vaccinate more people
faster the cdc says nearly 9 million
americans have received their first
vaccine doses but that's only about
one-third of the more than
25 million doses distributed our lead
national correspondent david begno is in
los angeles david what are officials
doing
to speed things up well they're standing
up more vaccination sites anthony and
they should because this country is
running way behind but take for example
what's going to happen later this week
disneyland down in orange county is
going to stand up a vaccination site
there they've already got the tents
where they expect to vaccinate thousands
dodgers stadium
is going to go from being a testing site
to a vaccination site
they're hoping to do 12 000 people a day
at the major league baseball stadium
and that's going to open on friday on
top of that here in l.a county we're
told they're trying to use
pharmacies and libraries and parks and
supermarkets
to also vaccinate people here's what
else is happening elsewhere around the
country to get more people vaccinated
from san diego to miami san antonio to
phoenix
there are mass vaccination sites coming
online
in cities around the country arizona
officials say nearly 44
000 people have made appointments at
their new 24-hour site
at state farm stadium nearly 29 000 for
this week alone
in new york city there are five 24-hour
mass vaccination sites that are now up
and running
i didn't think we were going to get it
this soon and so i'm just really
grateful to feel like i'm getting my
life back
to los angeles county now where supply
is also an issue
they were promised 1.8 million doses of
vaccine
but they only got 271 000 according to
county supervisor hilda solis
we're barely getting our fair share now
and we need to really ramp that up
well president-elect joe biden who got
his second dose of the vaccine yesterday
has doubled down on his pledge to
vaccinate 50 million people
in his first 100 days of office and now
he says he'll release
all three to available thousand people a
day dying is just beyond the pale
but unless officials loosen and simplify
eligibility requirements
soon the process will likely take far
too long warns dr peter hotez
of baylor university every time we've
added any level of complexity
it's either slowed us down or shut us
down entirely
and i think that's probably going to be
true of the some of the cdc
recommendations
we can't make excuses anymore we can't
come up small again
we've squandered every opportunity to
contain coven 19.
talk about straight talk from dr hotez
listen here in los angeles county things
are so bad in terms of
viral spread in the community that
yesterday county officials said if you
leave home for any reason to go get
groceries
for any errand that you may run when you
come back home you should wear a mask
in your home to protect your family from
you because
that's how dire the situation is here in
l.a county
wow david thank you very much we were
wondering why he was wearing a mask
indoors there's an answer for you